[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is shy Wilma Shaw who was a visiting
professor at the Council on Middle East
Studies at the Macmillan Center he has a
professor at the interdisciplinary
Center in Hertz Leah and the head of the
Middle East program there he is also the
Brian Mulroney professor of government
at Tel Aviv University professor mashal
has published several books on topics
relating to the Palestinian national
movement the Palestinian Islam the
political economy of Israel and the
Palestinian Authority as well as Israeli
Arab political culture and Shiite
leadership today we'll talk with him
about the communal dimensions of the
post Arab Spring in the Middle East
welcome professor Michele thank you for
having me on your show let's begin with
an overview of your research tell us
about it look the big question was what
happened in the last six years since the
uprising and the their armed rebellion
in the Arab world causing the Middle
East because this was something that
never occurred before I mean we had
rights but not to such extent and what
happened is it took so long that I
started to ask myself some question
among them uses another violent act or
something more harder than in used to be
and more more significant to what's
happening to the regime's and I came to
the conclusion that predict analytically
speaking I think what happened mainly is
the diminishing of the power of the
stage and the rising of the power of the
communities there always were there but
they were subordinated most of the time
to the authoritarian regimes and all of
the sudden every
think explode out and things are going
on up to this minutes and nobody can
guess what's going to be the future
right so what did you look at tell us
about your methodology look I try to
follow it by my some knowledge on the
social science well I built a kind of
perception multi-dimensional perception
they try to ask for question what are
the visions of both sides the regime and
the people who who are the opposition
what is the agenda the changing
environment and the resources that each
of them are able to use and I came to
the conclusion that there is a
significant difference between the pre
Arab Spring era when vision was clear
environment was defined very well
everybody knows its place and all of the
sudden things are start to change in a
way that they have to interpretate the
vision of each side to see to what
extent still believe in their ultimate
truth or values what happened to the
environment the change maybe their
attitude and position and how do they
set up their priorities in terms of to
what extent they are able to continue
getting legitimacy identification
participation of the people and the most
important things how it affect the the
policy that each of each side use in
order to further its interest I think
before the Arab Spring government
definitely use coercive means but not to
such extent they were relying more on
symbolic and nauru norms and maybe some
kind of rewards and benefits they try
very hard to continue this way but it
didn't work at least
some of the countries as we know their
place like Syria or Libya or Yemen that
it is really full-fledged civil war in
Egypt is much less violent and I think
we can say it's mild kind of Arab Spring
because there Egyptians except
exceptional exceptional that is okay so
the only nation and the Middle East
and they are important they it was
shortly speaking they joined the Arab
world officially only in the mid fifties
in Egypt we have a big argument who are
we we in Gyptian are European etcetera
but them they are real nation ok let me
ask you this when you use the term Arab
Spring it brings to mind for me
Egypt in particular did it did the Arab
Spring start in Egypt no it was the
second ok first place was December 2010
[Music]
Tunisia ok and then it spread to Egypt
today to Egypt and from Egypt to Syria
ok and so forth and so on because for me
as a westerner Egypt because in my mind
was a relatively stable nation and it
seemed like overnight it became violent
can you speak to that because you had
said it it basically happened overnight
and is that true or in looking at prior
to the Arab Spring where there telltale
signs leading up to what occurred there
were signs that it's going to occur but
nobody expected to that if no weapon at
this time and against Mubarak because
then you have enough to [ __ ] elements
that think those things will happen
they're waiting for the pooling
so the pushing factor were there all the
time so what are those facts our first
year of this huge gap between the low
class middle class and the high class
it's unbelievable I mean they're very
poor very the most of the population is
young up to age 19 and most of them are
poor they hardly can find a job and if
they go to university is almost
impossible to find something that's
suitable to what you studied and etc so
most of the people are in very bad shape
while the government surrounded by very
rich people and this happened in Egypt I
mean and it's it's become worse than it
used to be and the other hand I think
that don't forget the networks and this
public communication that never occurred
before I mean all of the sudden Orthodox
Muslim woman you know built the kind of
a network network I mean did social
media face role in this at all okay
including you might smile but I found
that they invented Facebook marriage
really I mean marriage through the
Facebook I mean it's unbelievable what's
going on there for the control of the
government and their their confidence
that they know exactly what's going on
because of many of several integer
intelligence services that follow almost
everything that goes in this country or
other countries but the think Facebook
did the job and many people discovered
the new world I mean it's it's it's the
serious aerial phenomenon that Arab
regimes or any other regimes
don't know how to handle it look at this
country I mean all this opposition
against the government against the white
house most of it I mean it's it's it's
energy and it's powerful influence I
think I'm from the network from the
Facebook at church and that's what
happened in the Arab world all of the
sudden they realize that the world is
different then things can happen by the
way the same year in 2011 there are
other places beyond the Middle East that
they have similar protests it was in
Chicago it was in Wall Street it was in
Spain which mean I doubt if we can just
minimize this phenomenon only to the
Middle East I think is spreading in
several other countries and I don't know
what's going to be in the future I know
that something changes drastically in
the relationship between what we used to
say public people and the government
since I don't know what's going to be
the future of course of the state or the
political structure in the Middle East
and I think that spreading beyond the
Middle East's we can see what's going on
in Europe people are confused people are
looking for some symbols new identity
and it's kind of different beliefs do
you think it has anything to do with the
really rooted in the economic troubles
both in the Middle East and in other
places in the world where people simply
are not being able to find jobs and make
their way in the world with a with a job
so I think economy is a symptom because
the end there is I think a new and
higher expectations from people of
what's going on
they live in different world this is a
shifting interest and the identities and
people have we they define themselves in
different place so I think the global
economy on the one that did very well
but for certain kind of people but I
call it not a global it's kind of Krakow
economy which means it's mix between
local and global and I think we have a
problem with this balance because the
local benefits and the global interest
and so far I think the world is
searching for some formula that nobody
knows how it's going to do what it's
going to be and how it's going to affect
the old world all the block not only a
Middle East but the Middle East today I
think it's kind of lay laboratory the
things happening there and in the way
this can spread to other places beyond
the Middle East so let's let's get back
to your paper in terms of you know the
the specific countries that you look at
and and the current situation who are
the the actors shaping the political
scene there today look the way I look at
it I always see high-rise building the
Middle East try to imagine it as
high-rise building on the top you have
those the huge big rich penthouses this
is a global power of course it's us
Russia you and the second level is the
local penthouse I mean the original
penthouse you have a Saudi Arabia you
have Israel you have Turkey you have
Iran maybe Egypt and then come all this
apartment building under this and that
under that the the penthouse on the top
of the tower and this is there in
tragedy and immediately some
them I destroy some of them are burned
some of them are facing the these floods
everything but the new phenomenon is
that the middle is all of a sudden
facing a basement and then in the in the
in the bottom of this fog rising
somebody built a basement and this
basement have all the nuns state
organization I mean they don't follow
the rules the political rules of the
region or the the states and the other
hand they become very influential and
influential in the way that if you look
what happened in the last three years if
you open the newspaper and you look at
their watch TV news you see Isis became
the leading power in the news I mean
Isis is the party that shape the
worldview of many countries world power
so you end the regional power you have
the u.s. you have Russia you every run
the European countries who fighting this
non-state group so something happened
happened in a way that that didn't
happen before is the real communication
in the Middle East is not between the
penthouses on the top in the state under
but when the bottom line with the
basement I mean it's unbelievable that
those small groups can shape the public
opinion their interests the priorities
the values of such big powers yes
because of the terror that they caused
around the world and then how that is
reported is very small but the small or
has such a big influence on our daily
life it's in New York
it's in the world it's all over the
world and they for sure trying to focus
on capitols and big cities because there
were the many ways so here in seeing the
effects of the kind of how to say absurd
communication between those terrorist
organization by the way not all of them
are the same Isis is just your East
organization but here is Bala and you
have Hamas that they are also in a way
deal with some social issues they look
at the community to the needs of the
communities of the people and their
their influence but generally speaking I
think the real phenomenon in the world
that maybe we don't pay attention to it
academically or analytically is the
emergence of those non-state role in the
organization which are called
communities so if you look at many
places in the Middle East
communities are leading the the agenda
and when you say communities can you be
more specific
yeah yes we're in those communities in
in Lebanon you have 16 Christian
sections for example in Syria you have
the allow is there the minority and they
run the country you are the majority
Sunni you have the Druze
you have the Kurds and tribes so you
have it's cutting across religious line
ethnicities tribalism extent families
etc and in this case the main difference
from my point view is that the
relationship within those communities
based mainly on trust while within the
state
based on contract let's say look at this
country I mean what kind of Allegiance
people have to the government it's a
matter of contract it's my I mean we can
talk about a relationship a citizen with
the government based on trust it's more
based on contract what should be done we
shouldn't be done I think in the Middle
East especially at this period when
communities are above everything Trust
is the most important element that
influence all the political climate ok
moving forward how do you see these
communities influencing the you know how
a country is governed it's hard to say
today
it depends what we're talking about
because it's not all of them are going
through the same the same phenomenon is
the same phenomenon of you know having
such a big disorganized order etc if you
look at Egypt I think it will stay as a
state because Egypt in comparison to
other Arab countries don't doesn't
suffer from this cleavages ethnically
vigeous tribalism etcetera you have a
very solid sense of Egypt nationality as
Egypt nationalism people are relate
obviously to their government into the
regime eg the system this is not the
question there are other Arab countries
there I think communities are especially
in countries what we defined as Fertile
Crescent this is the countries
surrounding Israel it's Lebanon in Syria
it's Jordan it's Iraq they built on
their structure built on earth
Nick group and tribal structure and I
think how this is going to affect the
political order the political system
it's very hard to say because on one
hand you have this temptation to say
listen if communities are so strong so
let's build something that will you know
give something to those community in
terms of sovereignty of control etc but
but on the other hand how these are
going to be able to run this very very a
very upheaval situation so and above all
they don't have any experience to run
countries based on Federation or
communities so we're in a limbo and
because I think we are in a stage of
significant confusion because nobody
knows how this is going to look ten
years from now for example but for sure
it's not going to happen in the near
future so what do you conclude in your
paper what I include that we are going
through very hard time and the Middle
East
unfortunately the war the local wars
will continue the protest will continue
the uprising of people it will have here
and there maybe it will followed by some
[Music]
efforts to bring to relatively some
maybe peaceful situation and open
dialogue between the parties but I don't
see there is anything significant to be
changed in the next few years unless if
the big power so to speak will be able
to force there in the other solution
their planes on the different parties
it's in and it's very hard to say to see
it happening in the near future well it
is difficult times for sure in the
Middle East I think in in many of the
countries there so you know I guess
we'll see have to see how things unfold
over the next few years yes I think we
have to adjust our expectation to this
uncertainties and I think this ensures
the center and sentence uncertainties is
all over the Middle East is very maybe
we went to the extreme I think it's
happening in many places but don't occur
yet so do you you had mentioned you know
perhaps having the EU or the United
States for instance interview intervene
in some of these situations I mean do
you think diplomacy really could have a
role in helping move things along more
peacefully for sure but you need it's a
necessary condition not sufficient and
because at the end you have so many
elements there from the top to the
bottom including the non-state
organization and the basement that
everything you do you have to think in
broad terms because you always have
somebody who is not going to like what
you're suggesting and he can you know
cause a lot of damages so this is
notated
I mean look what's happening now they
try to bring Hamas who is Islamic
Palestinian organization non-state but
it seems that is have enough power in
order to bring big Arab countries like
Saudi Arabia like
Egypt - like Iran to negotiate with
Hamas in order to influence to influence
him in one way or another so I said that
diplomacy is very crucial very important
but it cannot work in the traditional
way you have to talk simultaneously with
different people different languages and
always to shift according to the
circumstances ok well it will be
interesting moving forward to see what
the outcome is in many of these
countries thank you yes thank you for
being here with us know at that moment
that's that's for sure thank you for
being here with us what wanted to say I
hate each your tail and I found it's
quite hard to try to explain to the
student the full picture because they
used to very known political order
institution now it's worse it's yeah
there's a lot of moving parts in the
Middle East for sure yeah ok thank you
very much you're welcome for more
information about professor Michelle and
his research please visit our website at
macmillan report yale.edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you